[Music]
how's that baby doing it's good it's
doing good yeah you want to run how many
do you want to have that's what I wanted
how many how many are you guys gonna
have well I thought I thought I was I
thought we were out at two and then
actually you know you forget about that
first year pretty quick and then they're
I don't know I love that like I was
trying to explain it because lots of my
buddies have been going to do you man
what are you doing and I sort of go war
the two that we've met you wouldn't
think this but I think they're the best
people on the planet so I'm like they're
the best people I've ever met so I want
to meet another one you know so I'm
excited I'm excited you have as many as
you can until you until they stop you
yeah here's the thing when this first
started it started with George Michael
yeah and now you look back and did you
realize the magic of that moment when
you first did it that first time with
George of course not look you never know
if you try to set out to make a segment
on a late night show that's all you're
ever searching for is is what other
things that will define our show you
never think that two years in Apple
would be saying we want this to launch
on Apple music and the caliber and
people that we've got doing the show is
mind-blowing to us
but what has been your favorite what's
your favorite going forward well I mean
it's a bit like picking your children's
you know I mean but I really in terms of
the one I've enjoyed doing the most I
think was probably bruno like oh really
I got a bit depressed afterwards why
because I've been looking forward to it
for so long and I'm such a fan of his
that when we've done it I was like I'm
not gonna get to do that again you know
and so that was incredible and then in
this show I think I can't really pick
one of my own like so I've done with the
first one with Will Smith right which
was just a dream for me I see out the
show that the last episode is me and
LeBron James who which is the which is a
really amazing episode it starts in them
in an empty Staples Center and ends with
a huge huge ending to the series I
really enjoyed the whole Cyrus family so
it's Miley Noah Billy Ray everybody all
of them in a huge car is a really quite
amazing cuz you really feel like you're
watching that family on a road trip you
know
[Music]
you